We should tell him the truth
Welcome back everyone
this will be my doctor strange multiverse of
madness imax trailer video they include a bunch
of extra information in each of the scenes a bunch
of extra footage so there are a bunch of extra
easter eggs we didn't see in the previous trailer
that we'll break down if you're brand new to the
channel we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships too all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and let me know how many you spotted
in this video the opening shows us the doctor
strange of standing in front of a sanctum
that seems like it belongs to supreme strange
sinister strange whatever you want to call him
you notice that it's one level higher than
the regular mcu new york sanctum this is also
true of the other sanctum that he sees during
the trailer so you know it's not his sanctum
it's the same one where he's slowly making his
way up the staircase everything looks broken
around him it looks like it's technically the same
place like it's meant to look similar but it's an
alternate version of new york city portions of
reality around the sanctum have kind of bled
together so our doctor strange is standing on top
of a bunch of skeletons on dead earth next to a
similar park bench as the other sanctums but half
of sinister strange sanctum is breaking off into
this void of reality there's kind of this red halo
in the sky hanging above them with all these grey
clouds the rest of the area around the base of
the sanctum seems like it's this combination of a
bunch of different aspects of this reality a bunch
of different pieces of earth from across the earth
as if it's like a dark future version of what
our reality might wind up turning into eventually
the trees also look similar to the trees behind
him when our scarlet witch starts interrogating
him when he's wearing the plain clothes and it
seems like scarlet witch has trapped him in a
hex-like illusion somehow the landscape is all
serene there are these trees she's tending to
they talk about the concept of the multiverse she
mentions vision's warning and then it's as if she
pulls the illusion down the hex or she switches
between realities like either it's red before
or it's read after then the sky turns red
there's these broken tree branches behind
him that looks similar to the tree branches
that are around this version of the sanctum
when she starts talking about how people think
that she's the villain for breaking the rules
and he gets lauded as this hero the intercut with
the scene of him looking at a statue of himself
at another sanctum this is the other sanctum
i spoke of the statue has a totally different
vibe he doesn't have a goatee in everything
around him the sanctum the buildings nearby
are covered in lush plant life everything looks
amazing you also notice the window of the sanctum
the eye of agamotto that it forms here is actually
lower than our version of the sanctum in the mcu
he also seems like he's wearing a different cloak
of levitation in this scene in this scene the
cloak of levitation is completely red the back
is a little burnt patch here you also see the
red patch version of the cloak when he's falling
through realities with america chavez and you see
the dinosaurs behind them but when he's staring at
sinister strange's sanctum he has the blue patch
on the cloak as if he patched the cloak with this
blue patch at some point you also notice when
he's with the illuminati too he's wearing base
layers that are closer to his classic comic book
classic doctor strange outfit they said that his
outfit would get more comic accurate in the movie
my assumption that this idealized reality with
the plant life over all the buildings and it
looks like this really serene reality belongs
to defender strange because we know there are
at least three variants of doctor strange in
the movie are doctor strange sinister strange
and defender strange there are also three versions
of doctor strange in the official poster and two
versions of scarlet witch because we've seen
two versions in the trailer there might be a
couple surprise versions in the movie but i think
for the most part these five different versions
of the characters are the only versions we see in
the film there are crazy cameos but a bunch of the
other cameos are completely different characters
like x-men fantastic four so on so forth
then you also notice doctor strange is using
chaos magic in the dark hole this is actually
a big deal because previously we thought that only
a scarlet witch could use chaos magic we did see
agatha harkness absorbing it during one division
so remember that because in this other scene where
she's attacking the sanctum or it seems like she's
attacking the sanctum you see all these different
sorcerers put up magical shields and it seems like
the magic of the shields is being absorbed like
it's being siphoned off the same way that agatha
harkness would siphon magikoff so scarlet witch
could be using the same type of magic as zach
at the harkness because in the other trailer you
see that her fingers were blackened just like
act of the harknesses but the other big thing
in this scene where he's using chaos magic in the
dark hold it seems like there are two completely
different shots that they're combining into one
shot because in the background you notice while
he's weaving the spell the big circular window
of the sanctum is broken in one scene and fixed
it another they could be editing the trailer in
a really misleading way marvel does that all the
time or because traveling the multiverse is such
a big thing during the film he could be using
the dark hole to travel between realities and
they could be two completely different sanctums
because in one of the scenes there's a chair
and the chess set is in a completely different
location the official synopsis only says he's
using the dark hole to weave a forbidden spell
that involves the multiverse in reality but
a lot of people also think that they put the
chest set there to foreshadow the big professor x
reveal like as a bit of a wink behind the camera
meant to be a reference to the many iconic
scenes of professor x playing chess with magneto
they did that throughout the x-men series both in
the original x-men movies and in the newer x-men
movies with the younger james mcavoy and michael
fassbender magneto in fact the last fox x-men
movie dark phoenix ended on a scene like that with
them playing chess together but as deadpool would
say even though with all the timeline trickery
between patrick stewart and james mcavoy this
professor x in the trailer is not meant to be that
exact same professor x from those fox x-men movies
the producer implied that there were infinite
versions out there this was meant to be one of
them and he along with the rest of the multiverse
illuminati are just versions of those characters
that happened to join the multiverse illuminati
they also confirmed a long-running theory that
they are using the illuminati team name in the
movie we just been using the name as shorthand
because that's basically what they're doing
they're basically a multiverse illuminati but nope
turns out that they're actually doing it legit in
the movie they're all on scarlet witch's list so
we'll see if they wind up surviving the end
of the movie also i think that's one of the
reasons why they made these alternate versions
of the characters like this isn't the one
from the fox x-men movies you can also see much
more clearly that there are six regular chairs
and an empty space in the middle for professor x's
floating chair the concept art made it look like
the gold one from x-men the animated series we'll
see if the final movie version wound up being
the same for those of you wondering about america
chavez and the alternate realities that she takes
them to as they're running from scarlet witch or
traveling throughout the multiverse it does look
like one of them is an animated reality some of
you were asking me about this specifically you can
see her star-shaped hole break through realities
into an animated one behind them when they're in
this dinosaur prehistoric reality it happens
right as she's grabbing the eye of agamotto so
the eye itself could have something to do with her
ability in the movie but in the comics she doesn't
need any special device to trigger her ability
so she could just be grabbing it as a coincidence
and for those of you asking how he got the eye
of agamotto back supposedly it was destroyed by
thanos during avengers infinity war and then he
didn't have it during avengers end game he could
simply have just tricked thanos and it was a fake
amulet you never once choose your greatest weapon
oh fake ori could remake it or he could get a
different eye of agamotto during the movie from
one of the doctor strange variants there are a
couple ways to explain him having the eye again
for those of you asking about crossover with
the what if universe there is some crossover
energy because a version of captain carter as we
know from the trailer is going to appear in the
film but it seems like a lot of these multiverse
versions are not going to be the exact same
versions as what if like this animated universe
they travel to is not the what if universe
because the animation style looks completely
different so this is probably just a random
animated universe out there to show that there
are animated universes out there then in this
scene it looks like america chavez is getting
ready to use her ability inside a room that has
the same markings as the dark hole like this is
some ancient temple if you look behind her while
she's running over the altar there's a rams head
here there's also a ram's head on the cover of the
mcu version of the dark hold it also in this scene
with zombified defender strange it seems like it's
happening in the same place as this temple because
the runes above him here look similar to the runes
inside the temple speaking of runes obviously
runes very important during wanda vision when this
beast is yelling at america's chavez and she's
being forced to open a portal to another universe
the creature has similar runes on it as gargantos
does when he's in the street fighting everyone
implying that the same person is controlling
both creatures that could be scarlet witch
because she does have to get to this alternate
west view somehow and when she does make it to
this alternate version of westview and she's
with this version of scarlet witch the variant
some of you have spotted behind them you see a
picture of a plant that is the exact same picture
that we saw during the eternals movie you've been
asking me about this why is it the same picture
is this some grand conspiracy theory normally
you think that because it's marvel there is
something going on here but i think what's going
on is that marvel filmed both of these different
productions in the same location and they like
to reuse the same props because if you look
here the same giraffe showed up four different
times and four completely different productions
first it appeared during ant-man and the wasp
in cassie lang's bedroom when she was a young
child after infinity war then it appeared again
during avengers end game in the bedroom of tony
stark's daughter morgan stark remember they lived
at that cabin by the lake then in one division
it appeared in west view and then it appeared in
hawkeye in young kate bishop's bedroom in new york
again i think it's because marvel films these
movies these tv shows mostly in the same location
in atlanta and they like to reuse a lot of the
same background props when possible you thought
we wouldn't notice marvel but we did we did
there are a couple scenes with america chavez
and doctor strange in the illuminati cells waiting
to speak to them it seems like this is happening
after doctor strange and america chavez go on the
run through dimensions as they try to escape this
version of scarlet witch but if you did spot any
other easter eggs in this imax trailer with the
extra footage post them in the comments below
we'll get another new trailer pretty soon so
there'll be even more easter eggs after that
everyone click here for my new spider man no
way home deleted scenes video and click here for
my new marvel moon night episode 1 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!